foreign
you had an up close you know and
personal view of her work what's the
magic of Janelle Monae well that's hard
to put into a sound bite
but I think I think just her
authenticity and her her
expression of self and and her bravery I
mean she's a she's she's an amazing
woman I really love
that I got to not only get to know her
but you know become such good friends
yeah yeah you know this year marks the
20th anniversary of How to Lose a Guy in
10 Days can you believe it's been that
long no I can't I can't and I can't yeah
it feels like lifetimes ago but it's
also wild that it's been 20 years so
then to be a part of a project that like
still holds up and people still find and
re-watch I mean that's gotta feel
special
it is so re-watched it's so fun and like
right now I have all these young girls
like not 18 19 who come up to me and I
think they're gonna say like glass you
know what and it's all how to lose it
guys it's so fun I love it where's that
dress the yellow iconic no idea I would
keep it no I'm sure it's somewhere I
mean Paramount probably has it somewhere
[Music]